[Musique]
bon ça nous sommes en 1971 le grand
homme se lève va saisir un fusil sur la
cheminée puis il revient s'asseoir à la
table
il termine la rédaction d'un courrier
classique pendant ses deux jambes
puis il lève les yeux une dernière fois
au ciel à travers la fenêtre
il appuie alors sur la détente
je viens d'avoir quatre ans ma soeur mon
frère et moi partout alors à
l'orphelinat de la police nationale
selon les dernières volontés de notre
père cinq ans plus tard ma mère demande
l'autorisation de nous un récupérer nous
amener en vacances près du si beau
bassin d'arcachon où elle habite alors
nous habitons tout d'abord une petite
maison qui devient rapidement trop
coûteuse alors la seule solution est
d'aller vivre en forêt dans une cabane
occupé par un ami du nouveau mari de ma
mère la cabane est situé à 6 km de
l'école où je me rends chaque jour à
pied
il n'y a ni eau ni électricité
la chambre que nous occupons avec mon
frère est un ancien pigeonnier minuscule
et insalubres nous éclairons à la bougie
ont parfois la lampe à pétrole
il faut aller chercher l'eau au puits
et puis nous laver à l'eau froide a été
comme hiver dans une petite bassine
l'avion des rares alors nous chassons
l'écureuil et parfois des gibiers un
petit peu plus gros et quand nous
rencontrons nous partons à la cueillette
des asperges sauvages et de pissenlit
aussi bio camair la peur brisa pendant
des années l'incapacité à penser aux
meilleurs et sauf quand ils sont dus à
la nature
je n'est objectivement pas de souvenirs
heureux de cette époque j'ai compris tôt
il faudrait me sauver j'ai commencé à
travailler à 12 ans sur les marchés
j'ai vendu des espadrilles du fromage
comme je le dis parfois en fromage
plutôt pas mal bon fromage et j'ai
ensuite enchaîné les petits boulots dans
l'ostréiculture la déforestation
un soir en rentrant à la cabane
je découvre un trou dans une des dans
une cloison de ma chambre je comprends
plus tard qu'il est dû à une balle tirée
par un adulte au dessus de la norme qui
s'était endormi ivre sur mon lit je
comprends alors que l'heure est venue de
renoncer à ma propre famille ma mère
tente de me dissuader de me retenir mais
ma décision est irrévocable
nous sommes en 1983 je viens d'avoir 16
ans trois jours plus tard je suis
présenté au juge des enfants du tribunal
de bordeaux qui me confiait une famille
d'accueil
je peux alors terminé mon année scolaire
et obtenir mon cap2 mécanicien auto un
oncle me trouver un emploi saisonnier en
normandie et à la fin de l'été je décide
de rester en côte en paix sans autre
solution je deviens balayeurs et à 17
ans je vis déjà seul dans un petit
appartement dont je paye moi même les
factures
à mon retour du service militaire sans
autre possibilité
je reprends cet emploi mais quelques
mois plus tard j'ai l'audace de demander
à mon responsable de remplacer un
mécanicien qui va quitter la société
à ma surprise je reçois cette marque de
confiance et devient ensuite
effectivement mécanicien je reçois
également une augmentation qui me permet
de m'acheter le premier objet inutile de
ma vie j'ai une question pour vous qui a
un peignoir dans cette salle
et vous aussi vous êtes fait avoir et je
vous assure c'est vrai je me suis je me
suis offert un peignoir et ça ne sert à
rien un peignoir
qu'est ce que c'est agréable il y avait
près il y avait près de chez moi en
normandie un grand site industriel et
grâce à mon expérience de mécanicien je
postule et j'obtiens alors je deviens
alors ouvrier opérateurs de fabrication
comme on dit alors dans ce groupe et
j'intègre 7 cette société et je signe
alors un contrat à durée indéterminée le
sésame qui me fera sortir de la
précarité comprenant bien vite que mon
bagage initial est insuffisant je cumule
les formations long terme tout d'abord
puis en cours du soir et accor et par
correspondance
en 1992 j'ai 25 ans souvenez vous que je
travaille depuis longtemps déjà je vends
tout ce que je possède pas exagérer non
plus vers une voiture intevient rien
d'excessif mais je vends tout ce que je
possède et je pars en australie pour
apprendre l'anglais
à mon retour je retrouve mon poste je
réintègre la société et je poursuis mon
évolution
je reprends des études dans une des
écoles de plus en plus prestigieuses et
je crois qu'on en jeans ont fait aimer
sweet contre le costume mais un certain
temps à m'habituer à mon allure
endimanchés et je ne vous parle pas du
nôtre cravate
il m'a fallu un temps certain pour le
réussir quelques
et plus tard je prépare un master dans
une en 2000 en 2002 pour être précis je
prépare un master dans une grande école
de commerce
ai je choisi le thème de l'innovation
pour la rédaction en mémoire les longues
recherches ne conduise à une idée
complètement incroyable certains métaux
de leasing dans laquelle je travaillais
pouvait permettre de traiter les
cellules cancéreuses
essuyant l'incrédulité je ne vous le
cache pas du plus grand nombre
je poursuis seul je n'abandonne pas et
poursuit seul ce travail pendant deux
ans en parallèle de mes autres activités
autres fonctions finalement j'obtiens un
prix dans un concours d'innovation parmi
220 projets et j'obtiens enfin un budget
grâce auquel je peux développer cette
idée
tout d'abord en france puis aux états
unis où j'arrive en 2008 cette thérapie
innovante ciblé puissante prometteuse a
fait l'objet de plusieurs brevets et de
plusieurs premières mondiales en ce
moment même à houston des patients sont
traités avec du plomb 212
[Applaudissements]
merci et je ne vous cache pas que je
n'oublierai jamais mon émotion lorsque
nous avons traité notre première
patiente en 2012
à birmingham alabama elle était atteinte
d'un cancer des ovaires oui elle était
la première à recevoir ces traitements
j'ai finalement vécu huit ans aux états
unis
la société que je dirigeais a reçu le
prix de la fondation bill clinton à new
york en 2009 où son travail qualifié de
révolutionnaire donc ces mêmes travaux
le drapeau a mis à flotter en mon
honneur sur le capital de washington le
15 juin 2015
la cabane était loin pourtant présente
tellement présente encore au fil du
chemin
j'ai compris qu'il devenait nécessaire
pour moi de me défaire d'un héritage
trop lourd même si j'avais pu convertir
mon énergie de survie je dirais en force
pour advenir certains stigmates rester
trop présent en moi il y avait tellement
de colère et de tension la naissance de
mes enfants renforce à cette conscience
et mon désir de devenir le créateur de
ce que je leur transmets très ou pas car
la question de la répétition de la
reproduction est au coeur de celle de la
transmission et des héritages familiaux
ce que l'homme a devant lui c'est son
passé disait oscar wilde
en effet nombreux noms aux études
montrent que la question finalement delà
de la reproduction est davantage ancré
dans les rapports humains que ne l'est
la rupture ou le changement
je mesurais ce danger est le défi qui
m'incombe est peut-être plus difficile
encore que tout ce que j'avais réalisé
jusqu'à présent j'ai alors décidé de
travailler sur moi et à force de
psychothérapie comme généalogie
séminaire intensif retraite silencieuse
il verse thérapie retraite méditative
tout ça j'ai encore les lectures bien
sûr j'ai plus progressivement conscience
de la stratégie que j'avais mise en
oeuvre pour advenir
j'ai compris comment le socle de ma
sueur mobilisation était véritablement
lié à la peur de retomber dans la
précarité et à celle de ne pouvoir
offrir à mes enfants ce que j'aurais
souhaité recevoir moi même j'ai saisi
les insectes et des émotions et leur
rôle si fondamental dans la transmission
j'ai décidé de devenir moi-même
thérapeute en 2008
j'ai commencé ma formation à cleveland
aux états unis et cette année en 2019
je terminerai cette formation mené en
parallèle de mes activités à la vérité
plus j'ai exprimer les émotions resté
enfoui en moi et pour faire simple plus
je me sentais libéré
prendre conscience
son histoire de ce qui l'a déterminé la
ressentir vraiment puis la modifier pour
transformer le propre trajectoire
c'est ce que l'on appelle historicité
cette part de liberté que chaque
individu a sur sa vie et qui le rend
responsable de ce qu'il devient au delà
même de ce qu'il a pu recevoir
c'est ce chemin qui m'a construit grâce
à ça j'ai pu offrir à mes enfants
l'amour la tendresse l'affection sartre
disait l'homme est condamné à être libre
pour mes enfants
j'espère avoir pu modéliser l'apaisement
ça ne vois pas trop ce soir je sais la
confiance est résolument une
anthropologie positive avec mon frère en
2018 nous avons acheté une cabane dans
la forêt à 600 mètres à vol d'oiseau 600
mètres à vol d'oiseau de l'endroit dans
lequel nous avons grandi nous en faisons
un lieu de paix de fraternité de beauté
aussi
quoi qu'il en soit les plus grands
héritages sont intangibles et nous
conservons intacts que nous souvenir et
prouvé avec le temps une histoire et
mettra s'effaceront évidemment je veux
croire que mes enfants et ce dont
j'aurais croisé le chemin n'oublieront
pas comment ils se sont sentis en ma
présence je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]